chef de l'État est en déplacement en sc
etmarne sur le thème de l'exécution des
peenes Nicolas Sarkozi vient d'inaugurer
un centre éducatif fermé ce dispositif
créé en 2002 pour faire face à la
délinquence des mineurs et offrir une
alternative à la prison ferme le chef de
l'État va maintenant prononcer un
discours on l'écoute tout de suite en
direct il était temps de mettre à
l'honneur l'action du personnel
pénitentiaire et de souligner
l'importance de ces missions pour notre
pays vous participez à une politique de
fermeté que je n'ai pas peur
d'assumer parce qu'elle protège la
société parce qu'elle est indispensable
au maintien d'un état de droit c'est
vous personnel pénitentiaire qui
garantissez aux Français que lorsque la
justice est rendu la justice est aussi
appliquée il n'y a pas de justice si la
justice n'est pas appliquée la justice
ne doit pas simplement être
rendu la justice doit être appliquée
aussi à vous tous personnel
pénitentiaire qui êtes engagé dans le
service public
pénitentiaire je veux vous dire ma
confiance je veux vous dire la
reconnaissance de la Nation et je veux
vous dire l'estime des Français pour le
travail courageux et extrêmement
difficile qui est le
vôtre vous me permettrez d'avoir une
pensée particulière pour votre collègue
qui a été lâchement agressé à Nancy il y
a quelques jours aux abords de son lieu
de travail au seul motif qu'elle avait
été reconnu comme surveillante
pénitentiaire je pense également à votre
collègue surveillant du centre du pont
dont la voiture a été détruite par un
engin
explosif ces agressions sont
inadmissibles
elles seront sanctionné très sévèrement
et ces agressions illustrent
malheureusement les risques auquels vous
êtes exposés et ces
risques nos compatriotes doivent en
prendre conscience et doivent en tirer
la conclusion de l'estime qu'il doivent
porter au métier qui est le vôtre
chaque jour vous êtes confronté à un
milieu dans lequel règne la détresse la
violence le rejet de l'autorité la
misère sociale et la détresse
psychologique chaque jour vous devez
incarner la fermeté je l'ai dit sans
laquelle il n'y a pas de sécurité mais
également
l'humanité sans laquelle on ne peut pas
convertir au respect des règles ceux qui
les ont
bafoués chaque jour
vous êtes les garants des valeurs
républicaines je sais que la détention
favorise parfois les comportement de
repli sur soi les identifications
communautaires le renoncement libre
arbitre je connais les craintes que vous
nourrissez en constatant chez certains
détenus le développement des sectarismes
et des
prosélitismes rarement bien
intentionné et bien nous ne laisserons
pas s'installer dans les cours de nos
prisons la grande braderie des
idéologies qui mettent à mal l'ordre et
qui mettent à mal la laïcité à laquelle
nous sommes tous très profondément
attachés la République ne doit jamais
renoncer à faire respecter ses valeurs
et les valeurs de la République doivent
être respecté dans la prison peut-être
plus encore qu'à l'extérieur de la
prison la carrière pénitentiaire est
aujourd'hui considérée à la mesure de
son importance dans notre société
l'administration pénitentiaire s'est
modernisée son personnel s'est renouvelé
de plus en plus de jeunes
diplômés souvent des femmes viennent
rejoindre les rang de votre
administration comme en témoin de la
dernière promotion de l'École Nationale
de l'Administration Pénitentiaire dont
les élèves achèvent aujourd'hui même à
agin leur scolarité et se préparent à
rejoindre leur terrain je les salue
d'ailleurs parce que je sais qu'en ce
moment même on nous reçoit en direct
je sais donc que vous travaillez dans
des conditions difficiles en 2009 le
gouvernement avait signé avec vos
organisations syndicales que je salue un
accord qui a permis des améliorations
significatives plus grande présence
d'assistant social et de psychologues à
vos côtés renforcement du service de
nuit dans les établissements de petite
taille nouvelles disposition pour le
paiement des heures
supplémentaires votre statut également
beaucoup évolué avec la création de
nouveau grade d'officiers la distinction
entre le corps d'encadrement le corps de
commandement la nouvelle filière cher
Michel Mercier insertion et probation
qui se met en place cette année viendra
compléter ce dispositif je souhaite que
le Gard des saut poursuive avec vous le
dialogue sur ces évolutions très
importante depuis quelques jours le
gouvernement vous a confié une nouvelle
mission de sécurité vous avez désormais
la responsabilité de conduire et
d'escorter les détenus lorsqu'ils sont
présentés un juge
cette nouvelle compétence qui était
jusqu'àalors dévolu au service de police
et de gendarmerie vient confirmer
l'importance de votre rôle vous êtes
donc vous personnel pénitentiaire la
troisième force de sécurité que nous
avons voulu développer au service des
Français ma visite aujourd'hui doit
permettre aux Français de mesurer
concrètement les efforts qui sont les
vôtres les efforts de la France pour de
donner à notre politique pénitentiaire
un visage plus humain et davantage
conforme aux exigences d'une grande
démocratie en ces lieux peut-être plus
encore qu'ailleurs nous devons être
exemplaires comment exiger le respect
d'autruie le respect des règles communes
si nous ne savons pas les faire régner
dans nos établissements pénitentiaires
comment protéger la société si la
détention devait
inéluctablement rendre les détenus plus
violent encore comment faire appliquer
le
droit si la prison elle-même n'est pas
une zone de
droit dans ce domaine nous avons
progressé ces dernières années c'est
vrai sur le plan des institutions depuis
2008 le contrôleur général des lieux de
privation de liberté remplit une
fonction
essentielle grâce à la détermination et
la vigilance de jeanmie de la rue que
j'ai plaisir depuis mon élection à
recevoir chaque année et entendre dans
le détail ses remarques sur son travail
je veux dire d'ailleurs à Jean-Marie de
la rue que j'attache beaucoup
d'importance à sa mission qu'il remplit
avec discrétion avec le souci
d'améliorer les conditions de vie des
uns comme des
autres plutôt que d'augmenter le nombre
des articles qu'il a dans la presse
c'est ainsi Monsieur delaré que vous
avez gagné le respect de tous les
intervenants dans la prison et c'est
ainsi que le gouvernement monsieur dearé
vous écoute davantage parce que chez
vous il y a l'obsession du concret et de
la réalité de la vie dans la prison il y
a pas l'obsession de la médiatisation ce
sont des sujets trop
importants pour qu'on en parle sans
connaître et c'est également vrai sur le
plan des textes puisque nous avons
clarifié modernisé les règles du droit
pénitentiaire la loi du 24 novembre 2009
Mesdames et Messieurs les parlementaires
a consacré des avancées
considérables nous avons renforcé le
respect de la dignité des détenus en
inscrivant dans la loi le principe de
l'encellulement individuel nous venons
de le visiter nous avons garanti le
maintien des liens familiaux dans
pendant la détention nous avons
développé les soins en prison la
formation et le travail parce que la
prison ne doit pas être une période
d'oisiveté mais un temps j'ose le mot
d'effort un temps de
transformation ainsi que l'occasion de
renouer avec une activité utile à la
société pour donner plus de sens à la
peine nous avons développé des mesures
d'aménagement qui permettent une
réinsertion progressive comme la
surveillance électronique de fin de
peine qui permet au condamnés d'être
placés sous bracelet électronique
pendant les 6 derniers mois de sa
détention enfin nous avons voulu que nos
établissements pénitentiaires et les
moyens de participer pleinement à
l'œuvre de justice nous avons multipier
les rénovations de bâtiments et créer
depuis
2007 6000 places de détention
supplémentairire
6000 ce qui représente une augmentation
de notre capacité d'accueil en prison de
10 %. l'établissement de Réo reflète
parfaitement cet effort au même titre
que les trois autres centres
pénitentiaires qui vont ouvrir dans les
prochaines semaines à Nant à lance et à
Lançon il a été aménagé pour favoriser
une détention intelligente son
architecture ses équipements ont été
conçus pour rendre le détenu responsable
amené à rompre avec son mode de vie
antérieur et à respecter les règles de
la société l'ouverture de Réo permettra
de faire baisser le taux d'occupation
des établissements d'île-de-fance qui
est l'un des plus élevés du pays je
crois que c'est 140 % et contribuera
ainsi à une meilleure efficacité de la
justice car une justice efficace et j'en
viens à cette question essentielle c'est
une justice dont les décisions sont
suivies des faits et c'est par
parulièrement vrai lorsqu'il s'agit de
peine de prison qui sanctionne les faits
graves les Français ne comprennent pas
que les décisions de justice ne soient
pas exécuté dans des délais
raisonnables nos magistrats font un
travail remarquable dans des conditions
difficiles mais il faut que leur
décision soit mieux appliquée la
sanction doit pas seulement être ferme
elle doit être rapide car à défaut on
nourrit chez le délinquant un sentiment
et dans la population un sentiment
d'justice depuis le début de l'année
Michel merci a mis enuvre un plan
national pour réduire les délais
d'exécution des peines nous avons
renforcé le personnel des juridictions
accumulé plus de retard ces efforts
commenent à produire le effets le nombre
de PE en attente d'exécution a été
réduit de
15% donc vous rendez compte simplement
parce qu'on a la volonté de faire les
choses depuis le début de l'année nous
sommes en mois de septembre en 9 mois
le nombre de peines non exécuté a été
réduit de 15 % simplement parce que le
garde des saut a décidé et a mis en
œuvre un certain nombre de mesures qui
permettent d'avoir ces résultats mais
ces résultats pour encourageant qu'il
soi doivent être poursuivis et amplifier
il faut se fixer une nouvelle ambition
j'ai demandé au Premier ministre au
Garde des saut
de présenter dès cet automne un projet
de loi de programmation relatif à
l'exécution des peines pour exécuter
plus rapidement et plus efficacement les
peines proncées à l'encte des des
délinquants la chaîne pénale ne doit
compter que des maillons forts il faut
renforcer les moyens des services de
l'exécution de l'application des peines
augmenter nos capacités d'accueil en
milieu carcéral améliorer nos outils
d'évaluation de dangerosité et de soins
en détention alors notre premier
objectif sera d'agrandir notre parc
pénitentiaire à la hauteur de nos
besoins je voudrais que chacun comprenne
que ce n'est pas une question
d'idéologie que c'est une question de
crédibilité nous n'avons pas de complexe
à avoir sur une question qui intéresse
la sécurité des
Français regardons la réalité en face
aujourd'hui nous ne sommes pas encore en
mesure d'héberger convenablement les
65000 personnes détenues en
ni d'assurer rapidement l'exécution des
peines en attente et ce malgré les 6000
places créées depuis mon élection et
j'ose le dire parce que c'est la vérité
les statistiques le prouvent la capacité
pénitentiaire française demeure plus
faible que celle de nos voisins
européens et c'est faire preuve
d'angélisme que de dire le contraire
c'est refuser de regarder la situation
telle qu'elle est
er chotti à qui je veux rendre hommage
l'a clairement souligné dans le rapport
qu'il m'a remis récemment et dont je
partage pleinement les conclusions pour
assurer une exécution normale des peines
d'emprisonnement la France a besoin de
80000 place de détention c'est une
réalité qu'il faut regarder il s'agit
pas de dire qu'on est sans cœur parce
qu'on dit ça il s'agit simplement
d'avoir le nombre de places de prison
dont nous avons besoin pour y mettre les
délinquants qui ont été sanctionnés par
la justice de la
République alors cet objectif de 80000
places de détention va figurer dans la
loi de programmation qui sera déposée
sur le bureau des assemblées dans les
semaines qui viennent cela représente un
effort d'équipement sans
précédent qui sera achevé en
2017 il nous conduira donc à créer 30000
places de prison supplémentaires eu
égard au délai de construction c'est
donc dès aujourd'hui qu'il faut engager
cet
effort il va nous falloir trouver des
solutions
immédiates je souhaite en particulier
que l'on puisse ouvrir rapidement des
prisons dédiées au condamnés pour courte
peine ne présentant pas de dangerosité
particulière cette catégorie de détenu
constitue aujourd'hui la majorité des
personnes incarcéré et la plupart des
peines qui sont en attente d'exécution
sont précisément de courte peine
le garde des saau va proposer d'ici à la
fin de l'année une liste de sites
pouvant accueillir ce type
d'établissement pénitentiaires notamment
des terrains militaires ou des bâtiments
laissés vacants par le ministère de la
Défense parallèlement à l'extension du
parc pénitentiaire nous devons également
diversifier les structures on ne peut
pas continuer à enfermer de la même
manière un récidifice condamné à une
lourde peine et un primo délinquant
condamné à quelques mois de prison c'est
dangereux pour la sécurité des
personnels et des détenus c'est
contraire à l'objectif de prévention de
la récidive et c'est coûteux pour
l'administration pénitentiaire qui
consacre de fait les mêmes moyens de
surveillance à tous les détenus on ne
peut pas non plus ignorer qu'une partie
de la population pénale
osons le mot présente des troubles
psychiatriques ça doit pas être un sujet
tabou c'est une réalité que vous les
personnels pénitentiaire vous vivez tous
les jours et qui vous met gravement en
danger et qui nécessite un suivi
particulier pour toutes ces raisons nous
allons mettre en place des
établissements assurant des prises en
charge diversifier les un diversifi les
un sécurité renforcé et les autres
davantage Axès sur la préparation à la
sortie le deuxè volet de cette loi de
programmation renforcera notre capacité
après prévenir la récidive criminelle
est quand même le grand sujet nous
devons rassurer nos concitoyens nous
devons garantir aux Français que toutes
les personnes placées sous mains de
justice fassent l'objet d'un suivi réel
et efficace et qu'on ne les relâche pas
comme ça dans la nature sans que
personne ne sache où il se trouve c'est
la tâche qui est dévolue au Conseil
d'insertion et de probation qui sont au
cœur de cette politique et dont je sais
qu'ils sont Mobil dis il faut les
soutenir c'est pourquoi le gouvernement
a demandé à l'Inspection générale des
finances et à l'Inspection générale des
serv judiciaires de rendre un rapport
sur la mise à niveau des moyens et sur
l'organisation des services
pénitentiaires d'insertion et de
probation le garde des saau mettra en
œuvre ses conclusions là aussi pas de
sujet tabou pas
d'amalgame prévenir la récidive cela
implique de mieux évaluer la dangerosité
des détenus à chaque étape du parcours
carcéral à l'entrée comme à la S sortie
de prison le projet de loi prévoira
ainsi l'ouverture de trois nouveaux
centres nationaux d'évaluation qui
viendront compléter ceux de Réo et de
freine avec ce dispositif 1600 détenus
chaque année seront évalués par des
équipes composé de fonctionnaires
pénitentiaes de psychiatres de
psychologues pour être dirigés vers des
prisons adaptées à leur profil ou pour
être inscrit dans des programme de
réinsertion c'est un effort sans
précédent pas de une fois qu'on est
condamné une peine de prison tout le
monde ne doit pas suivre le même
parcours alors le traitement des
délinquants
sexuels là aussi arrêtons les tabou
arrêtons les hypocrisies et regardons la
situation telle qu'elle est le
traitement des délinquentss sexuels en
détention avant qu'il n'arrive en fin de
peine est absolument
prordial et bien nous allons mettre en
œuvre des moyens supplémentaires pour
que que les injonctions de soins soient
mieux appliqué et pour généraliser les
programmes de prévention de la
récidive les injonctions de soins c'est
quelque chose qui est extrêmement
sérieux et qui a été
traité jusqu'à
présent d'une façon qui n'est pas me
semble-t-il assez efficace c'est c'est
c'est un sujet
majeur un malade qui rentre en prison
profondément malade de ce point de vue
ne va pas sortir guéri par le simple
fait qu'il a été
enfermé regardons les choses en face on
le trouve avec une simple
parenthèse et il ne peut pas sortir dans
les mêmes conditions alors je sais bien
que la question du
volontariat est une question bien
difficile mais nous avons aussi à
protéger la société on ne peut pas
traiter
un délinquent sexuel malade comme on
traite un patient du quotidien qui n'a
agressé personne on ne peut pas leur
appliquer exactement les mêmes règles
dans le rapport entre patient et
médecin il y a pourquoi parce qu'il a un
trème élément c'est la
société qui connaît la la
dangerosité du délinquent qui est libéré
et qui doit être en mesure d'exiger un
suivi le respect des
injonctions savoir où se
trouve cette personne
malade et prendre les moyens pour
protéger la société on peut pas
simplement s'ent tenir à des principes
généraux c'est trop
facile oseraiis-je dire c'est trop
lâche pour vous vous les personnel pour
les victimes d'hier et pour les victimes
potentielles de
demain c'est un sujet dans le garde des
saau va débattre au Parlement sur lequel
je souhaite que chacun nous prenions nos
responsabilités que les choses soient
claires là aussi ce n'est pas une
affaire de gauche ou de droite c'est pas
une affaire d'opposition de majorité
c'est une affaire de
responsabilité le droit du
patient très
important mais le droit de société
protégée est au moins aussi important
voilà je je souhaite que on est bien
cela à l'esprit quand on
va aborder dans quelques semaines le
débat alors dans le même souci
d'efficacité il est me semble-til
indispensable que tous les intervenants
de la chaîne pénale puissent consulter
les informations pertinentes pour le
suivi des
délinquant dans le respect des
prérogatives de chacun mais arrêtons
avec le secret profession en la
matière enfin je respecte le secret
professionnel mais quand il s'agit de
protéger l'intégrité physique du
personnel chacun doit avoir accès au
dossier qui lui permet de mieux
connaître la personne qu' le
garde il faut donc organiser la
connexion des outils informatiques de la
police de la gendarmerie des
juridictions des centres de détention et
des services d'insertion et de probation
pour qu'on ne connaisse pas l'erreur
qu'on a
connu
récemment il a été décidé de remettre
quelqu'un en en liberté parce que la
dernière infraction n'était pas
grave enfin la dernière infraction
c'était la 22e il y avait les 21 autres
à regarder avant enfin vous comprenez
bienf vous connaissez ça très bien il y
a un
parcours il y a une
dont il faut tenir compte et dont les
professionnels que vous êtes tiennent
compte j'imagine que quand vous gardez
quelqu'un quand vous le regardez vous ne
regardez pas simplement la dernière
infraction qu'il a
commise mais l'ensemble du cursus qui a
été le sien 3è objectif de notre loi de
programmation le traitement de la
délinquence des
mineurs vous savez l'IMP